saviez-vous que dans la haute valallet
de Chevreuse un magicien des saveurs
opère il s'appelle marchenenus c'est un
maître artisan siropi qui transforme les
saveurs en hectare inspiré des
traditions médiévales il renoue avec cet
art ancestral de la siroprie où le sirop
n'était pas qu'une boisson mais aussi un
ingrédient culinaire
[Musique]
Raffin c'est donc au cœur de la cité
médiévale de Chevreuse près du château
de la Madeline que se trouve son bar à
Siro c'est un lieu cosi où l'alchimiste
et ses elfes vous emmènent pour un
voyage CHANS r uni imaginez-vous entrer
dans cette boutique au son d'un carillon
et découvrir ces effluves aussi
envûtantes que mystérieuxes des
aromatiques au fruité en passant par les
florales les épicés et les toréfiers
chaque sirop est une œuvre d'art
basilque citron Bella fig Vervain
gingembre tous sont créés sans aucun
arôme artificiel ni colorant ni
conservateur c'est un cadeau qui raviera
les palais les plus exigeants et qui
apportera une touche d'originalité à vos
fête